صباح العربيه دائما كان معنا في هذه في
هذا المونديال وهذه البطوله نايف ثقيل
نايف اهلا بك يعطيك الف عافيه كنت معانا
الطوال هذه التغطيه التغطيه الموندالاشي
22 كيف تبدو الاجواء بعد نهايه الموسم
اكثر في اليوم الاول من المونديال هناك
يعني ما يخص مغادره الجماعي هناك جماعي
بعد المباراه مباشره شخصيا كانوا يحملون
حقائبهم من الملعب الى المطار وهناك
جماهير همم فضل الله في البقاء ويعني هذه
الجمعيه نوعا ما هي الجماهير العائلات
يعني الذي الاب والام والاطفال في همم
الدوحه وقضاء جزء من الاجازه اجازه
الكريسماس وراس السنه وهناك يعني جماعي
وخصوصا جماهير البرازيل وايضا جزء من جميع
الارجنتين والدول البعيده همم يعني اقتلصت
البورصه للذهاب الى دبي تعليميه دبي يعني
احد المدن التي يحلم الكثير بزيارتها وفي
وصل منها فضله ان يختمه رحلتهم الطويله او
والجميله مع كاس العالم في همم دبي بالامس
كانت جميع المناطق التي شهدت الاحتفالات
وبالذات قبل الوسيله يعني قبل الوسيله
بالامس كانت شبه همم خالي هناك فقط
منطقتين كانت ممتلئه في همم الناس وهم
يعني سكان اهل قطر كانت منطقه كتامه
ومنطقه مشيب وكانوا يحتفلون باليوم الوطني
همم فيما فيما يخص ايضا ال- ال- المقتنيات
او على ماذا حدثت في الجماهير ان تقتني
همم
كذكريات معها وهي مغادره طبعا بالاكل انه
المنتجات التذكاريه لكاس العالم حيث قامت
يعني همم الجهات المسؤوله هنا بنقل جميع
النقاط البيع المنتجات الى مطار حمد همم
الدولي وعمل عليها صدري
اسمعك هل فعلا زاد ارتداء الناس للبشت بعد
ارتداء ميسي لا هو هل رايت ناسا بالفعل لا
يرتدون البشت في الشوارع
المنتجات بالفعل يعني تخيلي انه الجماهير
الارجنتين بعد المباراه
او في اليوم الثاني صباح امس اتجهت الى
سوق
يعنب المنتجات التراثيه يعني نفذت تقريبا
جميع جميع
انه سيكون هذا عنف بالنسبه لهم في كل
الاحتفالات طبعا بالتاكيد انه يعني جوده
المنتج تختلف كثيرا عن الذي
قبل تتويج بكاس العالم ولكن هو فضلوا
وشاهدتهم بالامس همم
وهم يرتدون ال ال الخليجي في سوق واقف
وايضا في همم وهم سعيد ايضا هذه من
الجوانب الايجابيه التي خلقتها او صناعتها
همم في خلال فتره همم
طيب نايف الملاعب نختم فيها الاستاذ يتحول
مجمع سكني ملعب 974 سيتم تبرع باحدثنا
اكثر عن الملاعب ومصيرها
دائما دعينا نتحدث عن ناصر الدعم اكبر او
ازمه تواجه الدوله المستضيفه لكاس العالم
هي ماذا ستفعل الملاعب نعلم ان جنوب
افريقيا الى الان تعاني بسبب التكلفه
الصيانه العاليه ملاعب البرازيل والتي
اقيمت في مدن همم ليست جماهيريه كبيره
تعتبر مهجوره الان ومبارياتها لا يحضرها
سوى اقل من 500 مشجع لذلك تنبهت لهذا
الامر قبل ان تبني الملعب او تقوم بتصميمه
وضعت في حسبالها ماذا بعد المونديال كما
ذكرتهم عن التفاصيل همم الملاعب وكيف سيتم
همم
ولكن يعني تحتاج قطر الى ان تلتقاء
انفاسها بعد المونديال ستبدا في مشروع اخر
وهو همم الملاعب ما بعد همم نعلم ان اهم
احد اسباب نجاح ملف خطا في تنظيم كاس
العالم هو اا تبرعوها بمقاعد الملاعب
تقريبا 179,000 مقعد وهذا يعني فوق حاجتها
ول- اا الدول الناميه هذا سيساهم في تقليل
وتقليس تكاليف الصيانه ولكن خطا قطر لن
تفقد ميزتها في في الملاعب لانها ستستضيف
كاس اسيا همم المقبله ويكون يعني عام
الجذب لاي بطوله مستقبل في كل مرحله في
حياتنا يا نايف دائما في اشياء جديده
واجمل ما في المونديال ايضا اضيفه مهنيا
انه تعرفت عليه سعيد
وتقبلنا على الهواء مباشره في اكثر من
اللايف تحياتنا لك وان شاء الله بنتقابل
كمان
شكرا شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا